congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
defending herself from accusations of
hypocrisy after wearing a tax the rich
dress to a star-studded gala where
tickets cost 35 000
oh my god tax the rich what a model aoc
i didn't know you model as well
when aurora and i were first kind of
partnered
uh we really started having a
conversation about what it means to be
working class women of color at the met
and we said you know we can't just
play along but we need to break the
fourth wall and challenge some of the
institutions and
and
you know while
the met is known for it it's spectacle
we should have a conversation about it
okay so housekeeping first she didn't
pay for the ticket she didn't pay for
the dress so just put it there um
yeah but
it was donated and i don't know what
you know i don't know what fec form that
goes on but
today everyone is talking about it isn't
this just which was the point right so
doesn't aoc just win
um
i guess she wins in terms of her her
goal of furthering the conversation what
she did everybody is talking about it
but i actually found this infuriating
and it has nothing to do with her dress
if you watch the way that these elites
were walking the red carpet they're
walking
unabated their faces are open they get
to smile for all the cameras and all the
working-class people serving them have
to be faceless they are masked and we've
seen this as a habit with the left and
she claims to be fighting for the people
and i watched a video of her having her
train carried through the carpet into
the met by a bunch of people working
there who were masks we saw nancy pelosi
do this with her big outdoor dinner
while all the servants many people of
color by the way
serving them we saw this with president
obama's party so this idea now of of the
left and the elites allowing the
pandemic and they've never had to deal
with it they all flew in on private jets
they don't have to worry about vaccine
mandates for their commercial travel if
they want to go see their family but but
the people that they think should serve
them and work for them they have to be
subjugated to all these rules so it's
not about her dress it's not about
criticizing her body as she said in her
defense of this this is about marxism
and what it communism at its core which
is the elites get to do whatever you
want and all the peasants and the little
people have to serve them and they have
to obey all the rules that they want to
just go to work for a day
dana what do you think about that point
a couple things so she is aoc antoinette
and this is the perfect event for her
the champagne socialists all get
together once a year
um and katie that is a very good point
about the the working-class people that
were there because the democratic party
has a little bit of a problem and the
republicans have taken a different
attack in the last several years that
they're more of the party of the working
class and you might start to see a
little bit more of this if the
republicans can figure out how to do
this
she didn't pay for the ticket the ticket
was donated
do you think that the person who donated
the ticket to the non-profit fundraiser
didn't deduct that from their taxes
of course they did and they didn't show
up in hybrid cars and green new deal
vehicles
they are right now trying to pass a 3.5
trillion dollar bill and reverse
engineering and like like it's going to
help all sorts of people and the trust
in government is at such a low ebb right
now that i don't i don't know if it's
going to pass or not the thing for her
is she knows how to get attention
she does it very well beautiful young
woman she's got a big following
my last point is
i really respect the designer aurora
james impressive person
but in her twitter feed aoc said that
she was an immigrant
okay she comes from canada right okay
it's not like she was like making her
way up from you know a really tough
place like bangladesh or nicaragua like
she came from toronto we could speak
canadian
so it must have been really tough
the other thing on that too is aoc is
not working class okay she grew up in a
very rich suburb she went to boston
university she was a bartender for a
short period of time and now she's a
congresswoman living in washington dc in
one of the most expensive buildings in
dc and she lives above the whole foods
and drives the tesla so
come on
bernie sanders would have stood across
from the steps of the gala it's great
and the coast with a little placard that
said tax the rich and a bullhorn and
that's a protest this is a performance
this is a pop star socialist trying to
get street cred for the slogan but also
wanting to hang out with celebrities
here's how this is going down anna
wintour runs the costume wing of the met
all right so she this is her gala i
didn't know there was a costume
there's a win it's incredible so
she
sends aoc a ticket
and
everybody else as dana said writes this
off as a tax deduction so aoc goes
she gets buzz the met gallup gets buzz
we're talking about it and all these
rich liberals get to feel like yeah
we're virtuous yeah sure tax the rich
and then the next day their accountants
are working 24 7 to lower their taxable
income the funny thing is aoc writes the
tax code
she's raising awareness okay we know
liberals want to raise taxes on the rich
we've known that for a hundred years she
could write a tax bill aoc hasn't ever
written a bill that's gotten out of
committee her entire career she just
lets nancy and chuck do it with a room
full of lobbyists they carve out the
loopholes and then in the next cycle the
republicans meet with the lobbyists and
they carve out loopholes they do it
every time
and you know she gets what she wants
six out of every ten dollars right now
if you work in new york if you have ten
dollars you have to give away six how
much more money do you want sixty-one
percent of everyone's income on the
books between state local and city taxes
goes to somebody else and yet most of
those people that are rich very few are
inheriting a lot of them are working 60
70 hours a week supporting other people
who are not working or who work for
government jobs the other thing is uh to
bring up mayor de blasio was also there
this guy's taken about poverty he's the
marxist who's really against the rich
and he's for the working class and he
hates cops and he hangs out with the
rich and famous that's where he's going
to end up in his years i just find the
whole thing detestable but i feel that i
i feel as though this is going to be the
preliminary to the mansion aoc
heavyweight bout that's going to be
taking place in two or three weeks i
don't know uh joe manchin was pretty
dismissive of her on the sunday shows he
was like we haven't really spoken i
don't really care she wants 3.5 children
you know he wasn't there at the met last
night after she's accused him all week
of being this rich expensive lobbyist
guy he doesn't want to spend he doesn't
want to spend 3.5 trillion
maybe he'll spend 1.5 hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else